what's happened overnight where you are
uh
hello studio uh today at uh
5 a.m uh we were bombed
by russian
troops
almost all bombs felt on the
city civilian
buildings i mean
houses of the people
and uh
we had a lot of bombs fallen and
unexploded almost 40 bombs fell down and
had not unexploded all the bombs were
this cluster bomb cassette bombs or how
they call it uh it's the big bomb which
uh divides on small bombs and then
explodes and kill civilians and people
so it's not about
fight with
military
troops but more with civilians and today
we are fighting with fire on those
buildings uh starting from the morning
and uh we still have no confirmation
about dead people because we were
prepared for for this bombing and people
were in um
in special places but uh about 60 people
endured
so uh
yes this morning was like you know
uh wake up call was with the bombs
i i wonder if i could just check with
you there mr mayor because i was under
the
maybe misapprehension that cluster bombs
have been banned so are you saying that
cluster bombs are being dropped on your
city this morning
sure right we have the confirmation we
have those bombs uh in
in my facebook i made a photo of this
type of bombs the small bomb what uh
left from it and uh yeah they they
for sure they use these cluster bombs
so these bombs that are banned under
international law are being dropped on
your city by uh by russian uh military
this morning
sure they they uh
there is no
another way that we saw that with that
bombs we have confirmation uh moreover a
lot of uh different journalists from uh
different countries made photos of these
bombs moreover they bombed also our zoo
so nothing no military object there on
in our zoo so now our zoo is the best
zoo in ukraine we're the best zoo in
ukraine and we have
now problems there and people uh
we we do
a special corridors and people go out of
the city right now moving to odessa this
is the only way for us to
escape
to evacuate people because
they gather with the troops around the
city from kirsan to
krapovninsky so almost let's say
three quarters of circle is closed by
their troops
um are they honoring that humanitarian
corridor mr mayor
uh no
so we don't have any corridors right now
because we have a
free road to odessa so
we haven't created any corridors until
we have this way to escape the sea but
the hurts on the city near us
for about 50 kilometers from us they are
closed and they don't have a green
corridor uh russian troops don't give
them a corridor we even can give them uh
the medicine the food
and they are really close so they
propose them
their help russian help russian medicine
russian food but people from the city
prefer not to take it and they made a
meeting there yesterday with the
ukrainian flags and saying that they
don't expect for russia to save them but
they are part of ukraine
mr um can the ukrainian people
understand
why
nato countries can't get involved with a
no-fly zone
uh you know uh the southern ukraine
is russian speaking moreover i would say
that in my daily life usual life i use
russian language as uh as native i i
think
uh using russian
so uh a lot of people were you know
kinda in love with russia because they
loved soviet union a lot of things good
things made in our city were made while
soviet union existence but
i think
no one i mean
no
people
who say that you we have here in ukraine
narcissist ukrainian nationalist they
never made more than putin made for
ukraine to understand that russians are
invaders that are
our enemies because they bomb our
russian-speaking language uh
people and uh
i think people uh
woke up
after so many years of
independence in ukraine
just before i let you go mr mayor did
you ever
expect in your lifetime to be in a
position
where russia invaded your country
to be honest
i became mayor in 2016 2016 and uh
before that i was i.t interpreter so i
was a programmer and uh
and i had a company uh and i think
everyone in the world understand that
there is nothing
um
good in war and we
never expected the world to come to our
country
but now we are in this situation we are
in conditions of war a lot of people are
really
uh
you know
frustrated they don't know what what to
do
where to run and right now i'm talking
to you and i hear the bombs uh
in our city so uh
no no one expected
we heard the information from uh
special services of the united states
and uk that put putting plans to invade
ukraine to
to go with to us with war but we
never believed in that right now we have
more
you know
we have all the evidences of this war so
and you see
the world seeing and we expect the help
as for nikolai we
we need really need hamlets and we need
uh west for our territorial defense uh
troops and uh
we're also gathering the
food
for long term
that can be long-term
story
i understand um oh
you're so brave and the people of
ukraine are being so brave and um be
safe in the knowledge that the british
people wish that they could do more and
are um raising as much money as they
possibly can to try to help your people
um hopefully this bloody war will not
continue for too much longer thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you thank you thank
you